billionaire investor ray dalio sounds
the alarm on a stock bubble that he says
is quickly approaching.com proportions
for the legendary investor rate value
current stock market valuations can
largely be traced to two things
high liquidity liquidity and low
interest rates
which i fully agree with totally the
fiscal and monetary stimulus measures
from the federal government and the
federal reserve over the past year in
response to kobe 19 are propping
propping up valuations and encouraging
investors to dive up share
prices as they look for yield but a
third in ingredient
investor behavior is also contributing
to the bubble forming
in stocks right now according to dalio
he also said his calculations told him
we're halfway
to the levels of some historic bubbles
and that investors ought to be wary
of weak returns and stocks going forward
by measures the bubble is not of what it
was in 2000
and not what it was in 1920 time but
it's 1929 but it's kind of
like halfway there tom gee why would i
not believe this guy he started
a hedge fund at the age of 26 he's worth
20 billion and he had the biggest hedge
fund at one time where does
what's the value for him for saying
something if there wasn't some evidence
and this guy knows what he's looking for
i believe him i believe him i think the
signs are there look tomorrow here's one
thing we all can look forward to
a three trillion dollar tax plan that
biden's gonna unleash on america
it's coming tomorrow all the details
higher taxes is going to be another fuel
for this whole thing
for a stock market crash it's coming i
mean i believe ray dalio i mean he's got
a 40 35-year track record of knowing
what he's doing and predicting the
markets i totally see this happening
so what happens if there is a bubble
what actually happens
so i mean i fully agree with what he's
saying that obviously there's high
liquidity and low interest rates and the
third factor he said was investor
behavior okay cool
so if there is a bubble was it what's
going to happen when this bubble pops i
mean the bubble popped
we had a 10-year bull run 12-year bull
run going on between 2000 great question
you're asking okay so what are we
talking about you got to say something
no i'm saying
i'm walking through this process right
now all right so the bubble popped
in 2020 and then what happened it
bounced right back
okay so what happens this time so it
anything to do with investing has to do
with your risk tolerance
with your asset allocation and with your
age so if you're young
if you're in your 20s and 30s there's a
bubble all right cool
look forward to the bubble and buy low
buy the dip and just get your investment
game on all right if you're older
and you're a retiree hopefully you've
changed your asset allocation into
freaking 70 80
bonds yeah and limit your exposure into
stocks is there a bubble coming
sure should you be freaking out no you
should have a plan
to adjust so also you got to understand
that people should be freaking out
some people should be freaking out you
don't think
you may not freak out you're 40. but a
62 year old having 70 percent inequity
right he should freak out okay but that
person should have a plan why would you
get that they're not 72 in equities when
you're 60 years old what are you talking
about
most people they just have their money
in a 401k and they don't know you can
i get that what i'm saying but you just
said the keyword they don't look at it
yeah of course they don't look at well
that's their bad yeah i get that but
you're you're asking what is the worst
thing that's going to happen you said
it's just going to come back up no it's
not going to come back up for the 62
year old
for the 40 year old that's fine if they
don't change their asset allocation they
don't change the asset allocation of
course you were talking about a bubble
in 2019 that rebounded in 2020. that's
not what dalio's talking about
he's talking about something half as bad
as the tech crash and the housing crash
he's saying more on those levels as
opposed to what happened a year and a
half ago
that's pretty bad so so let's ask
actually go back to your wonderful
question you asked ask the question
what's going to happen if there's a
bubble so what's going to happen if
there's
a filtering process yep and i think we
need a filtering process
do you know the whole story with uh uh
uh what do you call it forest fires you
know the story with forest fires
foreign sometimes they set it on purpose
to have trees died
that's new things yeah it's necessary
not not you go do it yourself
right sometimes our nature does it to
clean it up because the roots at the
bottom could have been stronger but they
were no longer getting the nutrients
that they needed because the trees got
the sun
they've been covering them up so now it
goes away and then allows for the new
people to come back up right okay
there's going to be a filtering process
but some people are going to get
hammered
i sent something out the other day where
i said the final one i put this on
instagram uh in in twitter
and i said the uh the next two years
will produce many accidental
millionaires and billionaires
it'll also produce many who rise and
fall
we won't know the real players until
2025 the cocky and overconfident
investor in any specific area will get
clobbered
stay alert stay alive right people are
about to be clobbered
there's a lot of money being spent on
things that is being overpaid by a mile
a michael jordan car sold for 738 just a
couple months ago
you know the same card sold last week
for 400 thousand dollars
okay from 738 to 400 thousand dollars
738 dollars there's 315 of them graded
at psa 10
that same card psa not the same exact
card but a psa 10 1986 fleer sold
last week for 400 000 and change okay
from 730 to 400 000 change same card
same exact uh one of the 315 cards right
what's the point
um you have to look at when people
are throwing money at things that are
not worth what they're worth but they're
just kind of like ah
i'll overpay ah i'll overpay that whole
thing up i'll overpay
it's okay i'll overpay because you have
the money to overpay
yeah people don't say ah i'll overpay
markets about to correct and the
overpay people are gonna go away a
little bit so it's gonna happen and it's
not gonna be pretty
the rates are going to scare the hell
out of a lot of people and
biden's three trillion dollar tax plan
that he's talking about they're about to
unveil
it will not be pretty it will not be
pretty look folks if you're listening to
this let's go to a complete different
direction real quick
completely different direction here if
you're listening to this you got to have
a real plan
on what you're going to be doing in
making money
the next 12 24 36 months where you
position yourself
where you're going to be what career
you're going to be into
what job you're going to have what
industry you're going to line yourself
up with what group you're going to be
running with
because it's going to be a three-year
run rate
of it getting pretty ugly with taxes
people are gonna feel it
opportunity is not gonna be the same
real estate is at its highest it's been
and there's a lot of realtors you talk
to them they all sound the same guess
what they all say
guess what they'll say the famous line
we don't think the peak is here yet we
don't think real estate is peaking we
think it's high
but we don't think it's peak time yet
right we think the peak is going to be
two years from now
no the peak is going to be 10 years from
now meaning
yes if i'm buying and holding long term
i'm going to be fine
but not the next two or three years when
the rates come back up
the industry is going to take a hit and
i think ray dalio is right i think the
market's going to take a massive hit
we also what what's the story with the
great dallas and you've interviewed ray
dalio so you've got some very unique
insight on this
it's i mean look i don't want to throw
shade at this guy because i do respect
him but
ironically i mean who does ray dalio is
ray dalio really concerned about the
individual investor out there
or is he thinking about the family
offices the his client sort of family
family office of course
so he came out in 2019 at in davos
switzerland
at the economic world economic forum and
what was his
famous line there that came out to bite
him in the ass was
cash is trash get out of cash well if
you're worth
a hundred million freaking dollars yes
diversify and get out of cash
yeah if you're worth four thousand
dollars cash ain't trash player yeah
all right so just understand when it
comes to ray dalio he's a different
perspective than the
individual person out there worth 20
grand 50 grand 100 grand or even a
millionaire
his clients are worth 10 20 50
hundreds of millions of dollars but he
was also talking about an event that's
about to happen
that potentially could happen or affect
everybody i mean i don't think it
matters who his
you know where he's getting paid by i
mean the bubble's still coming and
that's what he's saying
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye